nicest man in the world good kisser to
tell his wife hi I'm Emma Thompson loft
ammo checked and this is first and last
4th time
the first fake news story printed about
me was I had a lesbian affair in Sweden
overnight when I was opening yes
seriously
and they're literally totally made-up
and I was there with my mother having
made a film with my mother
the last fake news story printed about
me was that I had flown in from Los
Angeles to join the extinction rebellion
protest which was utter balls I came
home from work and I joined the protest
because it was there my first onscreen
kiss Jeff Goldblum in the tall guy we
had to spend three days naked doing a
sex scene which was then subsequently
picked up by the campaign against
pornography said they would use that sex
scene to show their children about sex
partly because at one point end up with
buttered toast on my bum my last
onscreen kiss was with Stanley Tucci in
the children act nicest man in the world
could kiss her to tell his wife the
first time I got drunk the first time I
got really properly absolutely ass hold
when I got to university there was a
this outdoor thing one day during the
day and we were drinking here which is
white wine with my my [ __ ] in it and I
had locked myself out of my college room
and I had to open the window and I came
in over the lip of the window and threw
up all over the floor so landed in to a
sort of carpet of vom the last time I
got drunk was weddings day my first
starstruck moment okay I met when I was
about 30
I was I knew this wonderful director
called Mike Nichols oh you might know
about you might not he introduced me to
Harrison Ford I went to meet him at
Paramount and I'll never forget the
conversation because Harrison speaks
very slow and I was being so it was like
a record being played that you
understand what I'm talking about
because you don't know what records are
but it was like and a turntable you know
with the vinyl was being played it's
like speaking a different language
my last starstruck moment meeting Nelson
Mandela on his 90th birthday yeah that's
that was a big one my first film role
was an impromptu an aristocrat with a
wig on that made me look like a cocker
spaniel and my last film role is the
Baroness in Cruella which I'm doing at
the moment which is why I've got these
nails because I obviously wouldn't
normally have these nails because I'm
not that sort of woman just in case you
were thinking I was the first time I
noticed everyday sexism I mean I became
a kind of card-carrying feminist when I
was about 19 so I think that the first
time I really noticed it was when I
discovered feminist literary criticism
when I was studying English I my whole
paper on the novel was feminist based
and I was definitely marked down on it
because I know I did a good paper so the
last time I noticed everyday sexism
whereas when I was on set but I counted
the people on the set and there were 30
men and four women yeah okay my first
trip to Hollywood was when I was 14 and
my dad took us to the supermarket but it
was amazing to me that you could buy
bacon and makeup in the same place that
was the first time and my last trip to
Hollywood was this year I
in Hollywood for my 60th birthday and I
spent it reading in the Sun the first
time I fell in love I was upside down
hanging off her clothes trolley in a
school production of Peter Rabbit and
Matthew Fox was upside down - and we
were 7 and the last time I fell in love
I simply cannot hi I'm still Emma
Thompson and that was first and last for
Tina
[Music]